well looks like we are boarding a very
familiar train once again and you know
what i'm on board for the conductor
right now because eric voss
never never jumped off the mephisto
train right till the very last episode
of wanda vision and believe me he's not
the first one to be bringing this back
after that image and especially the
personality behavior of doctor strange
in the spider-man no way home trailer so
i was expecting this video and of course
here it is spider-man no way home doctor
strange equals
let's see what eric voss is saying now
about this very very curious
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the spider-man no way home
trailer was filled with multiversal
intrigue multi-generational fan service
and
god damn it what's that doing in there i
was perfectly happy to look past this
and move on with my theory whips within
but most of us are pretty weirded out by
doctor strange in this trailer why does
he so quickly agree to help peter with a
spell that threatens the fabric of
reality and then admonish the kid when
it falls apart from the slightest
interference based on a number of clues
and this film's obvious comic
inspiration many of you are fairly
asking could dr strange be under the
influence of or himself be an illusion
cast by lift in the sensors here
marvel's devil methisto what i will say
is this question came up a lot during
the live stream and i'm just gonna get
the other way right now it could be as
simple as just the way the trailer is
edited when it comes to dr strange's
personality maybe there is more of a
debate to the idea of erasing the
existence or the memory that peter
parker is spider-man when doctor strange
is confronted with this question from
peter parker this could just be trailer
editing but you know let's let's see
what's going on let's hear let's hear
out some more so you got some more
it is the number one question i keep
getting and as your subservient nerd
theorist explainer i am going to answer
this to the best of my ability even if
it kills me and damns my soul but before
you comment that this is the one a
vision mephisto train all over again
like i could catch you before you wrote
that i know ninety percent of you just
kneed your comment directly on the
thumbnail without watching the video
seriously why why are you the way that
you are while i am personally bound to
mepisto when all corners of my life due
to a blood curse i don't want to get
into it i am also perfectly capable of
recognizing that mephisto does not
belong in every marvel title even when
loki's first episode included a freaking
devil sighting i shot it down and stuck
to my theory guns that it was kang all
along thank you god i get to keep my job
and jonathan majors has never looked
sexier my support of mephisto and
guanavision came mostly from that series
strong parallels to the west coast
avenger comics involving agatha harkness
memory wiping and wanda's children that
revealed mobisto pulling the strings now
yes some fans got carried away pointing
at everything as hashtag mephisto
convert but at the end of the day i
don't think it was that crazy to look
for the devil in the details in a show
about witchcraft but now going into
spiderman no way home i did not expect
mephisto to be involved in this at all
because this movie is packed enough with
multiversal magic peter angst and
endless cameos to have time for faustian
bargains but then this damn trailer
drags me back into the hell mouth
because peter responds to mysterio and j
john and jameson i just gotta say like
the fun editing on this video so far
it's a lot more quirky than usual
there's a lot more comedic bits than
ever so you know we don't shout out the
editors at new rockstars enough major
major props to you guys right now
because this is this is hilarious peter
responds to mysterio and j jonah jameson
exposing his identity and ruining his
life by asking doctor strange to rewind
everyone's memories but then gets second
thoughts when it comes to his girlfriend
his best friend and his aunt can't some
people still know that's not how the
spell works so mj's gonna forget about
everything stop tampering with the spell
ned he's my best friend oh my aunt may
should really stop talking
what just happened this sticks pretty
close to the plot of one more day
peter parker asking doctor strange for
help to save a dime aunt may and then
turns to someone later revealed to be
mephisto in disguise peter makes a deal
with the devil to warp reality so that
peter's spider-man identity is secret
once more but with major consequences to
his girlfriend and his best friend so to
think mephisto could be involved in this
movie it's not that far out of left
field but perhaps the biggest wtf moment
from the trailer was the fact that
doctor strange accepts peter's request
with no hesitation just a lie to wong
and a wink this isn't the doctor strange
that we know who when approached for
help by thor and tony stark toyed with
them and helped with only the slightest
assists that in some cases involved
manipulating them into killing
themselves it also could be different
writers for this time around you know
what i mean different people wrote
doctor strange versus the writers of
avengers infinity war this is the
spider-man films of the mcu which often
seem to have a much more light-hearted
affair when it comes to such matters it
could just be that for the comedic
levity moment of how that's all being
had like i'm seriously thinking that it
might just be the execution he could do
the wink and then wong leaves then
immediately he's like no peter go away
like i said that to get wong off my back
however no you're not off at all like
yeah it's like it's in terms of driving
for the one more day coming yeah it's
all it's all here already so going back
to like having mephisto in here is not
far-fetched also weird strange here
where's the eye of agamotto despite that
being destroyed by thanos and infinity
war and strange that's another big
question we got a lot since the time
stone was atomized now peter might not
know the necklace was destroyed because
during that wizard duel between strange
and thanos peter was busy saving the
guardians from floating away some are
also pointing to strange's hair because
yeah in passive incision films he tends
to always have a somewhat messy curl
dress comes back in the trailer here it
seems mostly neat also like that
and his sanctum is mysteriously frozen
over like the ninth circle of hell yet
he can cast a blazing fire with a snap
of his fingers also his mug bears
disgusting profanity okay yes i am
reaching with some of these really it's
strange's attitude toward peter
antagonizing him for expressing typical
teenage doubt for a spell strange should
have known better than to expose peter
to the problem is you trying to live two
different lives no it's not the problem
is you stephen strange breaking wizard
code to win over him
so strange combating peter in a wizard
duel on a speeding train and knocking
his astral projection out of his body an
attempt to snatch back this mysterious
cube which i had proposed could be a
pocket prison to contain extra
dimensional entities which peter himself
gets trapped in the trailer ends with
strange warning in a dark tone be
careful what you wish for parker which
again contextualizes all of this as a
wish fulfillment plot gone awry much
like one more day which again was a
mephisto operation now i think it is
reasonable for fans to suspect some
deception here and not just because of
that devil and disguised poster i mean
have you been to any protests people
putting devil horns on everybody but
really
hitler mustache has been about to some
extent deception tony stark fooled peter
by making him think he was in that iron
man suit just to reveal it was empty and
remote piloted and then deception the
whole thing
caught off guard when his homecoming
dates dad is the criminal he had been
chasing leading to the two of them
trying to out deceive each other and
then at the end of the movie tony again
deceives peter by making him think there
was no press conference when on the
other side of that door there totally
was and then far from home is of course
an even bigger deception game on peter
parker with mysterio gaslighting him
again and again even stalking him since
the beginning of that movie and even
peter's allies were actually
shape-shifting aliens in disguise this
just only adds more to the argument that
maybe we gotta get rid of some of this
whole mentor theme for peter parker
because he clearly sucks at picking
mentors all he does is get deceived by
all of this somewhere
is perfect tony stark did not ultimately
suck before all those comments come in
he did not suck they do lie left and
right to this guy yes that's how they
shape him is true deception see folks we
have been primed to trust no one who
offers to help peter in these movies so
back to the question is doctor strange
methisto i will say hopefully not
because not every liar in the mcu is
mephisto people strange is known for
quirky self-contradictions and
rule-breaking while there are definitely
some elements of one more day in no way
home i could see this simply as a doctor
seen a patient in need of wizard surgery
his admonishment of peter strange's ego
projecting his mistakes on others i just
think strange is a more interesting
character if he's not mepisto but if
doctor strange in this movie looks in a
mirror and sees mepisto staring back at
him while i will be obligated by blood
curse to stand and applaud i think most
audiences would be a bit thrown by a
mirror in a spider-man movie haunted by
anyone other than a loose norman osborne
ghost i was gonna say they need to
mirror that moment just with the doctor
strange talking to himself in the mirror
and revealing his true identities yeah
it's perfect i do think though it would
undercut the story a little bit i like
the idea of all this chaos goes wrong
and it suddenly make the movie about
something else much crazier and much
bigger already there's the fear that
this might be overconvoluted due to how
much is going on in this movie already
as great as it looks and as excited as i
am for it there is that uh trepidation
that maybe it is a little too much i
just feel like it would just completely
warp a lot of the viewing experience and
overall context maybe not fully warp it
but add a certain type of slant to it
where it's suddenly about that and also
you know like for people who don't know
who like kang is or he who remains that
was a thing when they watched loki where
a lot of people i know who don't follow
any of this stuff were like yeah
i don't know who that was i have no idea
anything what was going on at the end of
that to do that here with mephisto while
you already have so many other things
jammed into this movie yeah it would be
a weird platform like i still feel like
these details to me seem like they're
certainly leading to an eventual
mephisto presence it seems like they're
having too much fun teasing but yeah i
feel like for this movie's purposes
maybe it could be revealed in a future
installment that he was pulling the
strings here but i wouldn't expect the
actual reveal to be that unless it's
like the punch at the very very very end
or a sting or something yeah it's like
we were slowly transitioning into doing
multiverse stuff and now we're gonna be
using multiverses slowly transition into
supernatural horror stuff too so yeah i
think mephisto is definitely coming but
i wouldn't fully commit 100 right now
that it's in this movie if this whole
movie were to be revealed as part of an
ongoing illusion by mysterio plausible i
guess but it's gonna take a lot for that
to not feel a bit disappointing right
however i do believe it's not only
possible but likely that strange's
actions could be motivated by
supernatural forces like mephisto
full-blown demonic possession maybe
maybe not but strange has always been
more aware of the dark entities lurking
beyond this reality than he has led on
as mordo warned the bill comes due and
for strange i think the cost of his
mastery of the mystic arts is a mind
vulnerable to parasitic forces from
beyond when doctor strange looked ahead
at the 14 605 future outcomes he emerged
from that trance shaken with fear and
fear leads people to do irrational
things and i don't think it's crazy at
all to believe that one of the things he
saw was a demon that he now as i do sees
in every shadow manifesting as every
dark thought leading strange to use the
kid's wish to bend reality to
preemptively imprison every multiversal
evil in his weird little ghostbusters
trail and the way that one division's
post credit scene left us with
cosmic floodgates from marvel's book of
the damned i could see a post-credits
scene to spider-man no way home setting
up doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness with the implication that
strange's actions with peter parker were
done in the service of or the prevention
against that that i completely agree
obviously there's going to be a
post-credits scene because that's how
marvel works they have often have a
mid-credits that usually teases the
sequel or the next installment some type
of setup for spider-man and then the
post-credit will probably tease like the
next movie or something like that that's
not directly spider-man but i think if
like the ending of this movie was
movisto
suddenly like the conversation becomes
about doctor strange and not so much
about spider-man at that point when i
really am hope i just want this to be
about spider-man yeah if you get your
mephisto you probably want that to be an
introduction in multiverse of madness
and this would make for the perfect
springboard into that obviously by
having strange here to be such a big
part of it so if mephisto is not in
spider-man no way home definitely keep
an eye out for him in multiverse of
madness and in my case every time i
close my eyes to blake oh god oh god oh
god support rock stars by checking out
our merch options including our new
marvel what if limited edition shirt and
new rockstars.com follow me on instagram
and twitter at eavos follow and
subscribe to new rockstars thanks for
watching and uh again for everyone who
comments reacting to thumbnail without
watching the video honestly every time i
try to do something fun or exciting
you make it not that way i hate so much
about the things that you choose to be
a great clip
for that
you appreciate you saying all that but
all right guys well subscribe to new
rockstars if you haven't done so already
you can subscribe to us anyone who's is
some remotely covered spider-man no way
hope he's gonna keep on covering
spider-man though so many people
especially us we're already covering
spider-man no way home before the
trailer came out that annoyed people but
majority
enjoyed it in the video just kept
watching anyways so you best bet we are
still going to be covering this because
yeah easily right now i'm just counting
down the dates december 17th guys
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button we'll catch you guys soon